en esta ocasión tenemos una gráfica de
una función aquí dibujada y por este
lado tenemos varios enunciados acerca de
un límite o de varios límites cuando x
se aproxima a diferentes valores y lo
que me interesa que veamos es que hay
que figurar nos cuál de estos enunciados
es verdadero y cuál de estos no así que
comencemos con este enunciado del límite
de fx cuando x aproxima a 1 por el lado
positivo es igual a 0 entonces hay que
ver si es verdadero o falso entonces
cuando x se aproxima a 1 por el lado
positivo hay que ver qué es para valores
mayores a 1 y tenemos que checar cómo se
va a comportar fx entonces para cuando
es 1.5 vemos que fx se refleja aquí y
conforme nos acercamos a uno nuestro
límite por este lado no parece ser cero
sino uno pues así te pones a ver bien la
función se nota que está definida para
este valor en ese punto más bien si nos
acercáramos por la dirección negativa
veríamos que dicho
que se reflejaría que se está
aproximando a cero entonces cuando nos
acercamos a uno por el lado negativo nos
daría dicho valor pero por lo tanto es
falsa este esta afirmación y por aquí
hagamos de cuenta que tomamos este valor
del lado izquierdo cuando y conforme más
nos acercamos a uno tiende a este punto
indefinido de nuestra función y entonces
ese límite en ese caso sería verdadero
cuando fuera por la aproximación del
lado izquierdo ahora vámonos a esta
igualdad que tenemos aquí y la pregunta
sería si son equivalentes y la igualdad
se cumple para ambos casos
entonces observando nuestra función f de
x cuando se aproxima a 0 por el lado
negativo lo haré con lo haré con otro
color entonces es por el lado negativo y
tomando valores para x se refleja acá la
fx y se va comportando de esta forma
entonces esto luce de la parte negativa
como que está tendiendo a hacer uno y
por el lado
de hecho o parte positiva cuando x es
mayor que 0 vemos que en punto 5 esta es
nuestra fx ahora para punto 4 esta es
nuestra efe x y para x muy cercanas a 0
esto es f x entonces también
aproximándonos por la derecha el límite
de fx es igual a 1 entonces esto es
verdadero el límite de ambos lados son
iguales entonces son iguales a 1 así que
ésta definitivamente es verdad ahora en
este tercer caso vemos que este
enunciado nos dice que si el límite de
fx cuando x aproxima a 0 por la
izquierda es igual a 1 pero ya lo
habíamos pensado antes y vimos que
conforme más x se acercaba o se
aproximaba a 0 f x tendía a ser 1 por lo
que esta igualdad va a ser verdadera y
en este cuarto caso vemos que si tenemos
que ver que si el límite de fx cuando x
se aproxima a 0 existe y ya lo habíamos
visto esta igualdad nos lo dice entonces
también será verdad y luego llegamos a
este caso
que nos pregunta si es verdadero o
existe límite de fx cuando x se aproxima
a 1 y aproximándonos a 1 por el lado
positivo podemos probar para cuando x es
igual a 1.5 vemos que su gráfica de fx
luce algo así y cada vez que nos
acercamos más esto será igual a 1
entonces lo voy a reescribir para que se
vea más clara la idea entonces hay que
checar de ambos lados aquí sería el
límite del lado positivo y luego nuestro
límite aproximándonos a uno por el lado
negativo
vemos que conforme nos acerquemos a
valores menores que uno éste será igual
a cero por lo tanto el límite de mi lado
derecho es diferente al valor que obtuve
de nuestro lado izquierdo por lo tanto
el límite no existe entonces esta
sentencia va a ser falsa y finalmente
vamos a nuestro último enunciado que nos
dice que el límite de fx cuando x se
aproxima a 1.5 es igual a 1 entonces por
aquí todo lo que hemos estado tratando
de resolver anterior
ha sido un tanto más complicado
encontrarlo pero en este caso es como un
regalo como un helado de vainilla para
poder ver que cuando x se aproxima a 1.5
este límite va a ser igual a 1 o bien el
valor que toma f x para x igual a 1.5 se
pasará a casi la mitad de aquí entonces
efe de 1.5 es igual a 1 y ahora
aproximándonos por el lado negativo a
1.5 vemos que esto nos va a mandar a 1 y
el límite del otro lado del lado
positivo de igual forma entonces este es
un bonito ejemplo para poder visualizar
bien de lo que estamos hablando pues si
sustituimos dicho valor a nuestra
función vemos que no hay ningún tipo de
punto indefinido aquí y este es el tipo
de caso cuando el límite de la función
se aproxima exactamente al valor y
entonces esta sentencia es verdadera y
resulta más evidente